federal judge warned Michael avenatti
today the lawyer for film actress stormy
Daniels that he'll need to stop his
publicity tour if he was to continue
participating in the case as he entered
the Manhattan courthouse this morning
the president's personal attorney
Michael Cohen did not talk to reporters
inside his lawyer argued that the
release of Cohen's bank records by
avenatti
amount to quote a drive-by shooting of
his clients rights avenatti said he did
nothing improper and suggested Cohen's
team is illegally leaking recorded
conversations connected to Daniels while
there's no independent evidence to
support the claim avenatti told
reporters the tape should be released so
the public can decide their importance
relating to the president and what he
knew and when he knew it and what he did
as it relates to conspiring with Michael
Cohen to commit one or more potential
crimes federal judge set a June 15th
deadline for Cohen's lawyers to finish
reviewing 3.7 million files seized
during a raid earlier this year Bret